Every election,
eventually, you know,
the totally bonkers attack ads
start rolling out,
like this one
Ted Cruz's campaign
unleashed on Donald Trump.
Look!
I got the Trump action figure!
No way! It's huge!
-What does he do?
-He pretends to be a Republican.
(kids laugh)
-(laughter, applause)
-Whoa.
Huh? Sick burn.
Sick burn, bro.
There's no better
vote of confidence
than using eight-year-old boys
to relay your political message.
Believe it or not,
this is a high-budget attack ad
funded by a major
presidential campaign.
Uh, when you get
to the local levels,
candidates have
a lot less ad money
and apparently a lot less shame.
So I'm gonna show you
a bizarre local attack ad
that we found online,
and for 250 points,
I want you to answer a question
about it. First up...
Kay Daly takes aim
against her opponent,
who she calls a RINO--
a Republican in Name Only.
Let's watch.
And, you know, as a Republican,
you can be a RINO...
RINO... RINO...
I'm Kay Daly,
and this is my message.
I'm huntin' RINOs.
Care to join me?
(gunshot)
Okay.
Wow, that...
took a... took a sharp turn.
What else does
Kay Daly hunt? Tim.
Bargains at Old Navy.
HALE:
That's true.
Points.
Yes, she does.
Next up, an attack ad
against former
Texas state senator Danny Goeb.
("Let it Go" tune plays)
♪ I'll try to lie ♪
♪ Why should they know?
♪ Danny Goeb, Danny Goeb
♪ I can't lie to you anymore ♪
I was wrong. I didn't think
I could hate that song more.
Uh, what's another
one of the candidates'
Goeb-to karaoke songs?
Tim.
"Stay" by Lisa Goeb.
Points.
Uh, Reid.
"Wake Me Up
Before You Goeb Goeb".
-Yes, points.
-HALE: That's good.
-Now-now I kind of
want to hear that. -I know.
Uh, Tony.
Train's "50 Ways
to Say Goeb-bye."
Yes, uh, yes, points.
Points.
This attack on John Boehner
that has the balls
to parody a Viagra commercial.
You make a great team.
It's been that way
since the day you left.
But your electile dysfunction?
It could be a question
of blood flow.
Sometimes when a politician
has been in DC too long
it goes to his head.
Oh, wow.
I, uh...
I got to be honest--
I got to give 'em points
for "electile dysfunction".
Now, that's not bad.
That's something that someone
would say on this show.
I can't (bleep) on it.
What's another disease
voters can get?
What's another disease... Tim.
Congressional AIDS.
Wow.
-Points.
-I regret it.
-Yeah.
-I...
-Points, Tim Simons.
-I don't know.
I regretted it...
I regretted it immediately.
HALE:
That's all right.
Reid.
Rand palsy.
-Yes, points.
-Oh.